let's just get into the news so uh we're
hanging out with marjorie taylor green
you recently got permanently banned from
twitter i did it led to it contributed
largely and uh to people jumping over to
getter which is another twitter platform
now it's twitter like platform micro
blogging site some people have concerns
that getter is going to have censorship
as well because they have similar rules
but uh aside from you is also dr robert
malone a a scientist and a dissenting
voice in the whole you know covid uh
vaccine debate joe rogan then joins it
becomes this big story half a million
people sign up so i i want to get a
better understanding of this
why do you know why you got banned from
twitter
well we'll we'll go with the story okay
so here's what happened um you know i'm
an elected member of congress which
means the people elected me from my
district over 700 000 people are in my
district and i'm there to represent
their voice their values and and what
they want um out of their representative
in congress
and twitter being a private company
i don't know why they have decided that
they can be the judge of information and
misinformation but that is that's who
they have become i mean that's what we
see on most uh social media platforms
youtube also
facebook many of them and and over time
over the past years we've seen
conservatives be kicked off right this
has been a major issue and it's it's an
extremely important issue for many
americans
so on twitter
this was my personal account it's it's
my campaign account this is what i use
to raise money this is what i used part
of my reelection so it's very important
for me i have two twitter pages one of
them is my congressional page that's for
my congressional office it's an official
site and then i have this other one that
is the one that i i just got permanently
banned on
so it's it i'm not really sure what
happened but i want to go into it um
i had posted on january 1st a really
long twitter thread uh it was 20 20
tweets i believe and it was all about i
i started it it's 2022 and i i framed it
as let's talk about before covid and
after covid and i said it's like we have
a new era that we've moved into
and so each tweet i went through things
saying before covid and i would give
like what our reality was before covid
like um you know people didn't go to the
doctor unless they were sick i mean that
was what we used to do
as a mom i've raised kids i didn't take
my kids to the doctor to get a strep
test unless they really had symptoms
like a fever sore throat and things like
that so i was saying before covet this
is how we lived and then after covid now
we we get tested all the time for for
covid and so i went through every tweet
had that but involved in each of these
tweets i put um information that that i
had found in research like um
information off of vares which is
cdc.gov controls that that's the the
it's a site where people can it's
self-reporting um they can report if
they've had a vaccine injury any kind of
vaccine not just covet any kind of
vaccine or even a death
family members or a doctor can report a
death from any kind of vaccine so i had
talked about the vares system and
which is bothersome to me there's no
investigation into
the deaths that have been reported on
bears and as a member of congress i
think it's extremely important um so i
had this long tweet thread but then the
next day
i tweeted a few more things
um i had tweeted i had retweeted uh
someone's tweet about from a person that
was
celebrating and memorializing the
terrorist solomani that was that was
killed uh when president trump was our
president um this was a terrible
terrorist that had you know attributed
and caused the death of military members
and the loss of limbs
when they were over there and it's awful
and this person was just celebrating him
and his life and angry at president
trump that's on twitter
a lot of it oh yeah and i had retweeted
that condemnation of how can this guy be
on twitter
then i had seen a fox news interview of
one of my colleagues one of my
republican colleagues dan crenshaw
and as a member of congress we debate
policy right we should debate policy i i
would love to debate policy with all of
my colleagues
and he was on a an interview and he was
talking about fema and he was saying
president joe biden wants to do a lot of
testing and he was saying we should use
fema to set up and do this coveted
testing
and then he was also saying we should
use fema to go into the hospitals to
help with overcrowding
and that's that was what he was saying
we should do but here's the thing i
completely disagree with him and i know
for a fact that republicans and
conservatives and i would even argue
many americans would be against the use
of fema to just continue test and test
and test for covid
um
because
we should be more concerned about how to
treat covid these are just my opinions
not that i'm giving medical advice but
just my opinions
and so i had tweeted at dan crenshawn i
had said
no we don't need to use fema to do more
cova testing for sneezes coughs and
runny noses
and i said and we don't need to send
fema into hospitals we need to rehire
the unvaccinated healthcare workers that
were fired and they are
in some places some places thank god
because these people worked on the front
lines and they they save people's lives
and they have natural immunity that's my
opinion i think it's great and they need
to be able to continue their careers and
and support their families so that the
the dan crenshaw tweet was the last one
you put out and then they just they just
i had one more i i had to pick at aoc a
little bit but you know she was down in
miami enjoying free florida and martinis
and i was like that's a cup full of
hypocrite hypocrisy oh yeah she's uh
she's tweeted before that texas removing
the mask man date was going to you know
cause suffering i i i don't want to i
don't have the exact quote i read the
other day paraphrasing she said it was a
bad thing basically she said that ron
desantis could use some tips from the
governor of new york wow but she's going
to florida of course partying with no
mascon the thing is if she really
believes in mask mandates she could
choose to wear one
well let me tell you something yeah and
she doesn't always wear one and and but
not i don't i don't i don't want to
write right i don't want to drag i mean
i see her at work so but i'm curious uh
look it's it's 20 22.
elections are coming up and
we saw what twitter did with hunter
biden's laptop story right for those
that aren't familiar a huge breaking
story about hunter biden the son of the
president uh and and
just
malfeasance i'll put it that way the
story gets suppressed on facebook and
twitter and there are polls showing that
if people had known about the corruption
then a decent amount of people would not
have voted for joe biden that gets
suppressed i'm wondering if your
suspension is just following it's some
kind of political tactic it's political
and here i want to tell you why so the
reason why i bring up dan crenshaw the
tweet is because i told them this you're
not conservative you're hurting our
brand because conservatives don't
promote the use of fema for testing and
unvaccinated healthcare workers being
fired we don't want that and it was it
was within an hour after that tweet that
i got uh permanently banned from twitter
now here's something interesting
everybody always talks about politics
and money right
so they were saying that i was being
kicked off for covered misinformation
but um you know i started wondering i'm
like why is some people's political
speech accepted
and and promoted on twitter whereas
other people's political speech is not
accepted and as a matter of fact is
kicked off and i think that's an issue
so i started looking at who's on the
board at twitter and most of them are
democrats and most of them donate to
democrat politicians
but there's also someone that's
relatively new to twitter his name is
paul singer and he's a he's a mega donor
for republicans um and so i had
looked into some information on him and
i was like wow does he donate to dan
crenshaw
turnout he he does donate to dan
crenshaw as a matter of fact he donates
a lot of money
to dan crenshaw i would argue that he
helped him get elected by the amount of
money that he donated to him he also
donated to a pac that has benefited dan
crenshaw
it was money spent on his his election
and so
i think it was called the american
patriot pack um it supports a lot of
veterans running for congress and it
that pack had spent hundreds of
thousands of dollars on his behalf i
think i do have it here unless i'm wrong
there's opensecrets.org it says singer
paul new york
twenty seven hundred dollars to dan
crenshaw right
and then and that's just a single
contribution i don't know if if that's
usually a max contribution i think the
max contribution's gone up now to 2900
per candidate but you know this is this
is commonplace so he's a mega donor but
i want you to think about this this is a
guy that came on to twitter and it's
very interestingly
he was so important he was able to get
jack dorsey removed from his own company
wow that's who paul singer is
of elliott management and him coming on
to twitter
was
he he bought a lot of the shares he
became a major shareholder and then him
coming on board he was able to kick jack
dorsey out of his own company i think
that's significant and then this is a
guy that donates a lot of money to
politicians and so and he's not a fan of
mine and he's also not a fan of former
president he's not giving you any money
oh no no no he wouldn't give me money
because i don't say and do the types of
things he supports
so i can't prove this this is just
something i'm talking about because i
think these are the type of things that
do play
a role behind the scenes and i think
they're important i i really do and i'm
saying that um not only as a member of
congress um i'm saying that as an
american also and i think that when
twitter has overgrown uh its position
and i really believe it has because
twitter is controlling political speech
absolutely controlling political speech
not just for american citizens but for
members of congress and i would say
that's that's actually an attack that is
actually a political attack against my
brand of politics um i know paul singer
hates president trump he was a big fan
of marco rubio and that is that's an
open open known thing so
i'm not really sure but i don't think
that it was just covered missing no i i
think it's political and i think some of
it is
it's not just twitter it's youtube as
well there's there's stuff that we can't
talk about on youtube youtube would shut
the stream down in two seconds of course
and that's wrong
so we're we're not having real
real political discourse in this country
when the the common spaces that we use
twitter facebook youtube etc are in the
control of one political you know one
political faction that's right and they
just say well you broke the rules the
private platform i can do what i want my
it's crazy to me because i grew up
liberal and we were always complaining
about big corporations suppressing the
commons and and and hurting the little
guy in the working class yeah you know
what i feel the same way now i'm
watching it happen yeah and worse it's
affecting politics like
you are a sitting member of congress and
your voice people need to hear it so
they know what you're saying when you're
there voting on things and twitter is
like no we don't think that's important
well i'll tell you what i have a term
for it i'm sorry real quick it's on the
twitter twitter it's not sitting there
saying we don't think it's important
they're saying
it is important and we better not let
people hear it yes no exactly so i have
a term for what you're talking about i
call it corporate communism
and corporate communism is something i
just made up because it made sense to me
it's these large corporations
controlling
and usually they're affiliated with the
government so take for example you've
got a mega donor a republican mega donor
on twitter that hates me
and likes other types of republicans
that are different than me and so
wouldn't he play a part in getting me
kicked off let's get rid of her we got
rid of president trump they're hurting
the type of republican brand that we
want i think this is really scary and
here's something that's great here's
what i know about all americans
when you sit down and talk to each other
we all care about the same thing we do
most of us care about
we can find so much in common together
by being able to have these discussions
on these platforms then we can really
find apart from one another and that's
why i think censorship is so wrong well
i think the biggest problem with it is
we've we've gone through a bunch of
different uh forms of data showing
people who are on the left in america
whatever that means like the general
term
only get their news from lefting sources
and people who are centrist or
right-wing get their news from a mixture
of sources
so when you have people on the left and
the only thing they've ever heard about
you it comes from the new york times or
the atlantic or something they think the
worst craziest oh they do crazy things
and if you censor those if they censor
you
well then how are people actually going
to hear what you think
you can't and so there's this view of
you especially if like you pulled your
wikipedia page that's just it's insane i
want you to know i have kept that there
as a badge of honor that's awesome
because wikipedia is just it's whatever
anybody types on there and i think
people should know that about wikipedia
it's not truth
um i've never tried to change it it's
it's what other people have gone and
written about me nothing that i've ever
written about myself or or even that
i've cared to make sure is is factual
and i've left it there for a reason
because i want to be able to prove to
people that look wikipedia is someone
else's words it's just like a fake news
article written about me or someone else
and that's the craziest thing to me is
how
well i've talked to james o'keefe
wikipedia in these articles it says from
wikipedia it doesn't say from random
users like these these statements may be
an aggregate of different people putting
it together wikipedia puts their name on
it so i think they should be held liable
for defamation i totally agree with you
i agree with you 100 and here's the
thing about wikipedia is let's say that
i wanted to fight it
i could i could have one of my staff go
on there every single day and fix it and
and correct the misinformation someone
else can go on there and change it again
yeah so yeah with wikipedia putting
their name on it they are the ones
liable for the lies and slander
libel and slander about about people
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time